hallo leute wir begrüßen euch vom
alexanderplatz hier in berlin bei uns
ist da sie will sei mit dem wind nicht
perfektes wetter für diese episode ja
was ist unser thema heute facebook
facebook leute vorstellen ein thema wo
ihr wo alles was irgendwie mit zu tun
haben entweder hassen sie es oder sie
lieben ist sie sind den ganzen tag
online was das peinlichste was er jemals
gesehen habe auf facebook wir fragen
jetzt die leute zu ihren facebook
gewohnheiten und geschichten
bis gleich
wo ist denn die vier eigentlich gar
nicht richtig
relativ wenig also meine meine freundin
ist es ja klein und auch die leute die
ich damals trainer sind sehr sehr rar
was die posten oder so leute die nur
petitionen teilen eigentlich gar nicht
nehmen so habe ich es ja gut aussortiert
was postet ihr bilder ja wenn meine
lieblingsmannschaft tore schießt so
videos also so peinlich dass manche
leute ihr ganzes leben größten gratis in
den schreiben ja ich muss etwas club was
magst du zu posten
ich brauche ja gar nicht schreiben das
mit freunden kennen beispiel von mir
selbst erwarte ich mal auf einer feier
gewesen und dann haben wir beim
kostümwettbewerb mehr als frau
verkleidet und das bild hat eine reihe
stellt aber weiß nicht so schlimm aber
ich hab's dann später wieder rausnehmen
lassen aber das wäre jetzt ein beispiel
was mir einfällt benutzt du auch
facebook oder auch nicht aber bin
eigentlich mehr oder weniger nicht aktiv
kai nicht aktiv so gut wie fix was
andere leute posten eingecheckt hat mir
schon mal angemeldet und ab und zu mal
mehr schreibt antwort ich vielleicht
aber eigentlich eher selten
zurück auf der straße und jetzt nicht
mehr und wir interviewen jetzt dass sie
echte menschen
ich habe mich müssen eingedeckt mütze
ist ja erst mitte mai wasserer facebook
nein nein ich oft auf facebook nein ich
habe kein facebook habe echt weil du
bist die erste treffen in rom mit dass
mir zum mainstream jeder wirklich
brauchst nicht bist du also jemand der
die ganze zeit alles teilt was er macht
oder er so ruhig beobachtet ich glaube
es gelöscht
also warum einfach so einfach so macht
man das doch nicht doch doch welche
sozialen medien du das ne protzek und e
mail rolle sonst ja vor dass leute
irgendwie was sagen oder was verabreden
und dann sich auf facebook verabredet
haben du kannst nicht mehr drehen
ja schon aber es macht nichts die leute
die mir wichtig sind die schreiben mir
auch so
dorsten
da hat sich zwei stunden lang gefilmt
wir tanzen der disco zwei stunden und
wer hast du so eine tendenz wer benutzt
dass er und warum bist du nicht
vielleicht leute die nicht so richtige
soziale kontakte haben also alles von
sich im echten leben machen sie gar
nicht so viel
instagram instagram instagram ist
irgendwie nicht so ganz also man weiß
nicht gleich alles über die person aber
kriegt auch hier mit als schweizer marc
instagram weltethos mögen sie nicht
interessiere mich nicht so sehr wenn
leute über ihr essen nicht so viel mit
kommt gerade eine million zuschauer hat
eben auf facebook gesehen dass wir hier
sind und ich habe ihm geschrieben
okay wir fragen nicht direkt hallo hallo
hier kannst du usa wo in den usa aus dem
taxis texas haben viele zuschauer in
texas und jetzt seit wann bist du in
berlin
sorry seit wann bist du in berlin
samstag ganz frisch was teilst du so
persönlich von der facebook gar nichts
gar nichts oder
so bist du erde typ der alles guckt was
sie an so probt und glaubst du das leben
wert schöne ohne facebook oder eine
schöne westliche unbedingt facebook das
leben verbessert oder eher
verschlechtert verschlechtert was ich
auch richtig gut wenn leute ihre eigenen
seiten licon sich vorher einer sekunde
vorher geschrieben haben hat somit so
auch heute war ich da drauf und nach weg
sternchen sternchen das habt ihr ganz
ganz schlimm die kommunikation unter den
leuten finde ich hat sicherheit voll
verschlechtert dadurch also generell
durch social media finde ich mehr
kommunikation als früher ja aber keine
persönliche kommunikation treffen wo ihr
am tisch sitzt und wieder ist ein handy
ja und das finde ich echt grausam
ja ich hatte das auch es war schön mit
dir via super für mich sehr gefreut dass
du uns in berlin besucht hast ja ich auf
und gehe aus dass das thema schön war
aber wir haben noch nicht ganz so viele
antworten bekommen deswegen schlagen wir
euch mal vor dass ihr uns mal auf
deutsch in die kommentare schreibt was
ihr an facebook möchte oder nicht mit
postet das mal hier unten ihr könnt ihn
heimlich die sache genau die
eigentlichen sagen genau zeigen sie mal
erzählt uns mal was ist was geht gar
nicht was sollte man niemals auf
facebook posten das würde uns
interessieren sie auch unterschiedlich
in der welt in anderen kulturen naja ich
habe in essen gesagt was interessant war
weil es nicht peinlich als langweilig
vielleicht schreibt uns das mal hier und
ihr könnt natürlich auch über andere
social networks reden wie
youtube twitter instagram wobei die auch
ein bisschen andere kultur haben also
unser ziel ist schon über facebook zu
reden in dieser episode
danke fürs zuschauen wenn ihr unser
projekt unterstützen wirkt freuen wir
uns wahnsinnig freuen uns über jede
kleine spende
das könnte hier unten machen weil
patrick und ihr solltet unbedingt
abonnieren und ihr solltet auch damals
kanal schicken
den könnt ihr hier neben ansehen und
dort alles erfahren zur deutschen kultur
denn dana berichtet als amerikanerin ja
jede woche aus deutschland gegenüber
komische dinge in deutschland schöne
dinge auch dankeschön auf wiedersehen